foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I think I saved it
[Music]
I think I saved it
that was so quick I made a new stream in
like 10 seconds chat
insane
insane
how we doing can you all hear me are we
good are we good are we good
[Music]
yeah the other one the the the frame
rate dropped immediately and OBS
completely crashed
and I'm like all right that ain't it
made a new one 15 seconds
with some new settings and now I think
it's fine
might drop a few here and there but
it'll be okay
yeah it's like OBS doesn't want me to do
a mage build it's just because the
internet's different here and my OBS
isn't used to it yet
you like the starting soon screen Max I
like it too I think it's cool
we're gonna try and complete this play
through today
depending on uh how Melania wants to act
today
uh if I don't feel like fighting her I
won't
[Music]
good to hear GB good to hear good to
hear
yeah a friend of mine Katie gave me this
uh this playlist
it's very very cute
very Zelda e what's gonna be the streams
after Perry becomes Lord I want to try
speed running
I really want to do that I think it
could be actually super fun
uh we'll we'll see though
it's not a guarantee
however Chad I have a surprise for you
today
if
she wants to join us
she's not out here
Joe
[Music]
might be coming
he loves the bedroom man
Joy
come here
dude she is dead today
we went on a super long walk this
morning
and she is just sleeping
I'll go get her I'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
it's true
[Music]
it's Joy
[Music]
just wagging her tail
can you get up
[Music]
that's uh that's her spot she likes this
spot
I put this little bench here and she
likes to look out the window
[Music]
she's getting used to the new place
[Music]
she's pretty cute though
excuse the
major light coming through the windows
right now
you going back to bed
[Music]
I love you
you can lay on your chair you won't go
on porch
[Music]
why do I come back and I hear feet I I
look at Chad and it says feet
you can see her
look at that
[Music]
she's on the porch
[Music]
yep yep
shirt you're wearing compliments your
build
[Music]
thanks I'm definitely not uh I'm not a
twig boys
you locked her out I mean I can't just
keep the door open it's cold
can you see your mom
right here
[Music]
she's okay
[Music]
um
[Music]
all right
she's been sleeping like crazy man she
loves the bedroom she's in there
constantly
um we like I said we went on a super
long walk today
and then uh she got back and she's just
been dead asleep all day
get rid of the big window yeah like that
guy from yesterday
[Music]
she got barked at by a few dogs today
too
she did
also that's my mom Chad if you didn't
know AGT Mom that's like actually my mom
just so you know
do do
[Music]
okay let's finish this build today man
yesterday we beat morgot in about
15 seconds
because we have 60 and
kind of insane
I didn't think it'd be that good
I'm sure it's only good against certain
bosses though
can you pass the playlist link yeah yeah
I'll put it in chat hold on
bear
I'm just gonna share the artist all of
his music is like this
paste there you go
enjoy
Harry hotter is essentially God
he really is
the essence of God
you got it
does Perry hotter use parries not really
no
not really we're trying though like if
we get against like a magic build
it's possible
we also beat the fire giant yesterday
and if you know anything about me that's
kind of insane
I don't like the fire fire Giant
let's listen to Melina though I always
love this cutscene
unless you guys
don't want to do this
I have long observed
we could go down under isn't dying and
become and death
Lord of frenzied flame do you want that
ending to commit
cardinal sin
what do you think
well I can still become the Lord of
frenzied Flame
while doing this as well I always ask
this whenever we're here and I always
forget
do you know when the member stream is
going to be deleted do you mean the
member only Discord it already is been
it already has been deleted
burn Melina
hmm
all right let's go down under tell me
when you are fully prepared
we'll go down under
we'll piss her off
Let's Do It
[Music]
um
here's fine
are you guys just like super down bad
today because that's what's going on
because I got up and I had two
compliments on my body which thank you I
appreciate that and then several people
said feet because I do stream barefoot
I think we're all just a little down bad
today
just a little little down bad I'm going
the wrong way
you've never seen what's down there
it's Monday I don't feel like the day of
the week has anything to do with that
right
or it shouldn't I don't know
hey it's fine Chad I'm not I'm not
judging
no judgment here
whoops
ask me if I've gotten a lantern yet
I have not
feet are disgusting there's mold on them
what if I told you I wash my feet
and that there isn't mold on my feet now
what do you say
nice windows thank you I I can't do
anything about the windows man it's
bright
it's 7 A.M in the morning
or 7 A.M 11 A.M the sun's beaming
through
I can't do anything I I could close the
blinds but then Joy gets mad
we can't get joy mad that's just sad
I'm already lost
can't see okay I'm dead it's over we
dead
somehow I live
God gamer
oh here it is
let those dogs out to hang
dude I've seen some streamers they say
they they stream with shoes on and I'm
just like
are you insane
no I have not gotten the lantern
ow
come on
oh well we'll be right there
turn Bloom to Max and Elden ring best
challenge run
dude my um
my most recent video has started to get
an influx of views out of nowhere
which makes me pretty happy
like it wasn't it didn't really do well
initially and now it's starting to like
peak in viewership I'm like what the
frick
that's good it only took two weeks
no my most recent video the the
challenge run the the Rune roulette
it's like with radon yeah
I talked about this yesterday
but the um the radon video which is my
most successful video on my channel it's
like 920 000 views almost a million
that video is at 500 views for two weeks
and then all of a sudden just blew up it
was insane
out of nowhere
Elder Crow arise now ye tarnished and
remember to like the stream dude shrew
Chad who hasn't liked the stream yet can
we talk about that bro
who hasn't liked the stream dog
well that's not good
foreign
those are projectiles oh my God
uh oh
I did not know that
why did I agree to go down here why did
I say yes to this
why did I say that Elder Kroll Crow
thank you for the five I appreciate it
man thank you and like the damn stream
chat
it's the only way to grow a stream
with those videos getting a delayed
views it really seems that ER loves to
delay Jake good stream and videos keep
it up agent dude right
is there another way to go through this
area chat that I'm just dumb about and
thank you Angel for the Super Chat I
appreciate that
I'm tired of social media delaying my
[ __ ] I want instant gratification
hi Quinn
use Perry ability oh you're right okay
okay
I guess I have to get through this area
initially don't we
just walk the right path
oh only to skip the stairs okay
I at least know about it yeah we're
getting the three fingers
Chad wanted me to do the frenzied flame
ending
which for Perry hotter I think makes
sense
blade of
twisted
let's go
thank you man for the five gifted
memberships
those will be spread out into the stream
as we go along
so if you get one make sure to say thank
you
I'm pressing the wrong button
all right I'm gonna Parry these
I did it
it didn't do any damage
I also can't see
it did not work on that one
I did not see that last one by the way
okay he's downhill so we're good
W's in the chat for twisted bro
I did it
oh God they're killing other things
no
so nervous
thank you again twisted
thank you man
freaking Legend up in here while I'm
doing this [ __ ]
we will not be talking about sucking
toes excellent
this is good how's Joy doing
she's asleep on the patio oh
she did see a husky earlier
and she said
she barked was not happy about the Husky
but then I gave her some tummy rubs and
she was okay
I think re-firing the comet I just don't
like how I have to keep backing up
because nothing kind of staggers these
guys
last and common Azure him the only issue
that I'm thinking of here because I was
thinking of that as well but an issue
I'm thinking of is the fact that there's
three of them
like we're only dealing with the first
one right now
there are three
why do those guys hurt so much
okay I think I am just gonna run past
this guy though
as soon as he jumps
yep
we're gonna give it a shot
there we go that's what we wanted
look at these guys
stupid idiots
I'm gonna open that over there too
why did you just stop moving
you spiral Shard spell beat the game
with it hits up to three times
I have been told this a few times
okay here we go guys should we try and
attempt the skips
am I invisible right now or something
I think we needed that maybe not
do you say my balls itch or my balls are
itchy I say my balls itch
for sure for sure
nothing worse than an itchy ball sack
man
okay
how do I do this again
kind of like this
I mean wow
have you ever seen anything like that
first attempt
wow zero deaths I was fully expecting in
my head to be here for for at least 20
minutes
see this is why we need to try speed
running chat
the runs invalidated okay drips
okay bro
I am actually excited to try speed
running for this game though I really am
it'll be the glitchless speedrun just so
you guys know okay I'm nervous about
this
um I'm not very good at anything
but here we go
flask
calmed azure Kamehameha
excellent
half Health just like that
uh okay
okay
I don't really know how to fight you
without a sword
it's not even that good
I'm thinking slicer
why can't I see it
I'm thinking we slice them up
yep
yeah I kind of want to use Rock sling
again
ow
[Music]
how's uh spiral here
that was so poggers
I always forget about that one
where is
no
okay we're fine
chain cast it
right
you guys forget that I'm just really
good against Moog
what's up
why do I talk man it's like every time I
talk dude
oh I recently subbed for your cool
lorevids but why are there two mugs so
this is not real Moog this is a
um what would you call him a
not a clone but a
projection of him
just like Margaret
same thing
Bang
that did not go as well as previous
thank you
an illusion a hologram these are good
words
I like these words these are good
projection
as I said a shadow
so it's not really him and the theme
song is called Omen illusion so take
that as you will
really good at Moog okay watch this
watch this I'm I'm tired of this slander
from my chat I'm tired of it bro
watch this
why did he do that
I got stuck on a bench that's not my
fault
okay
foreign
that's not good
I want to flask it up
I'm really not a fan of the Spiral chat
I'm just not
even close
also no we're not at plus nine yet
I'm really good against I'm really good
against smoke though
if you couldn't tell
really good
really good
I get so distracted
[ __ ] I forgot all right
how's Joy doing chat
you can see your little head
foreign
she loves it out there this morning I
like tried to get her to come inside
like three times and she just like
wouldn't move from that spot
watch you fail
use your summon
now summons are for
Noobs
stupid losers if you beat the game with
summons you didn't even beat the game
near Trench
try this again
look at that timing
doesn't get better than that chat
just summon Brown
no I don't I don't want to use summons
I'm better than a summon chat
I beat this game with no vigor
you all saw it
I hope
and if you haven't seen the video I
don't know what the heck you're doing
we should watch it
I'll piss
he just splattered me
foreign
ly I can do this
clearly
can I do this to his blood
probably not right
I think it has to be a projection
Joy can do better
she's guarding the house right now she's
busy she can't prove it to you
oh I should buff outside the window you
guys told me that yesterday
yo my bad oh [ __ ] I forgot
that's not good that literally defeats
the entire purpose has done it oh no
spam
okay
Mr delay
that wasn't even a delay I was just
spamming
look at that
we're gaming
that was dumb
foreign
nice
I'm kind of pogging out right now
it literally completely disappears
okay you said not Clause I'm an idiot
that was my fault
foreign
Harry Potter's coming into his own here
boys
no I don't know what to do there
brig
what should I have done
should I have Kamehameha
wait no shot that reaches this far hold
I'm going for it
there it is
there it is
Perry hotter is figuring himself out
easiest clap of his life
he's finding himself chat
he's becoming who he's meant to be
the Elden Lord
which was your favorite game before
discovering from software
I have always said this and it will
always be my favorite game of all time
Sly Cooper 2 Band of Thieves is the best
game ever made
to this day
you all don't know what I'm talking
about I don't want to talk to you
if y'all don't know what I'm talking
about I don't want to talk to you
we also have this
Sly Cooper 2 Band of Thieves is the best
game of all time
should I upgrade my vigor
probably a little bit right
yeah
I see JoJo
she's good
I'm worried about her chat I'm worried
about her
pronouncing Kamehameha wrong you mean
Kamehameha or however you want me to
[ __ ] pronounce it you weeb
Sly Cooper
oh no
let me go spend all these runes
I already did
yep you got it
you got it
[Music]
for people outside the U.S it'd be Sly
raccoon wait is that right
why
the best game of all time is outer Wilds
or
Diego Elysium and if he disagree it's
because you're stupid in the head
yeah anything that's different from my
opinion is wrong and stupid
right guys
hmm
someone barked at Joy but joy did not
bark herself
okay I didn't mean to do that
we're fine
we are all good in the hood right now
guys
here we go
this is gonna be a first try right
[Music]
Velma is really that bad Velma is the
worst TV show I have ever seen
it is awful
it couldn't be worse and I'm not kidding
I think it's a shame that it exists
and it shouldn't exist
and I hope soon it doesn't
I was doing so [ __ ] good and then all
of a sudden I wasn't anymore
am I just like
I feel like I jinx myself and it's in a
me it's immediate Karma
like if I call myself a God I have to be
humbled right away
it's kind of weird like isn't
I didn't even say it that time man
I
I just said the word god
call myself a god
I didn't say it karma I feel like Karma
doesn't know how it works with me
just shut up
I'm streaming I can't just not talk
right
[Music]
imagine if we had the normal like jump
mechanics of Dark Souls games
and not a dedicated jump button
you imagine
I think I'm doing pretty good right now
though
[Music]
okay it didn't it didn't do it that time
we're good
we did it
all right chat you're all lucky enough
to uh be in the situation here where
Perry hotter has to strip his clothes
are you all ready to see the body of a
true God
here it is
damn
look at those yams
let me do a little pose for you
actually yoked
insane
this is what Perfection looks like
perfect
chiseled
experienced
now time to get why am I so dirty like
my body is I think it's because I'm old
I think it's like pot marks or whatever
dude I love my dog so much he's such a
good dog
she's just mad chilling on the porch
right now
it's
adorable
it's her first day she spent the night
here last night and today's her first
day here
so I'm
I'm you know I'm gonna be looking for
her a lot today just to see how she's
doing you know
she's doggy she needs all the attention
she's got her little spot up here that
she can sit and she has a little bed on
the floor and she can always go in the
bedroom and lay there if she wants
she a good girl
she'll be fine once she's pissed all
over everything she doesn't do that
she does not uh go to the bathroom in
the house she is potty trained
Joy is a dog she's right there
on the porch
yep we just got fingered
pain
man
foreign
this was the right decision
your dog looks like a sofa
he's on the sofa you idiot
this is a sofa
he's right there
forehead
all right let me let me get decent again
for you guys
excellent
yeah
kind of upgrades we got
sword
and this
she has become the sofa
she's protecting the family
should we go this way
secret tunnel wait do I not have access
to it or something
it is
how do we get a full Dog stream I don't
know what we do with just Joy
she likes tummy rubs
will you play Hogwarts Legacy do you
guys want me to play Hogwarts Legacy
also I really want to watch the uh Last
of Us show tonight
I've heard it's really good
dog cam
hmm
Giga Karen who's that
hmm
yeah you guys should like the stream
though it's true
the game looks pretty fun
here's
here's what's gonna happen with Hogwarts
Legacy guys
and you can clip it ship it
and come back to it when I'm right
because I know I'm Gonna Be Right
because honestly what I'm about to say
can't be wrong
either
Hogwarts Legacy is gonna be an absolute
Banger of a game that everybody really
really likes
kind of a mix of God of War
an Elden ring
or it's going to be complete and utter
trash
it'll be broken it won't work and nobody
will like it
wish YouTube had specific redeems like
twitch so that we can set up one to feed
Joy treats
if you guys want to do that that is a
thing I can set a donation goal and then
there can be a link to that
so every donation would go to that bar
that you could fill if you wanted should
you ride that could be fun of Chaos
I will kill you because she doesn't eat
treats and she needs toys and she needs
food
why is she telling me this here
oh duh because I just I thought this was
a different dialogue I wasn't really
listening
make Joy fat
no you go girl
should go girl
he did already [ __ ] you
oh hi on life yeah yeah
I did play high on life
now it was on stream or it was on the
channel because I streamed the entire
game
high on life
they both got they both got copyright
struck
because of a movie that was playing on
the TV in the game somewhere
and I'm just like damn
so I deleted them they gone
you had to be there to enjoy it
so now they're secret streams
yeah the movies actually exist and they
bought the copyright but apparently
obviously I don't didn't
so I got copyright struck
I vote for trash to be honest on
Hogwarts
from what I've seen it looks I don't
know
if you do play Hogwarts at least make it
a charity stream and raise money
okay I'm not gonna go that deep with
that
you should have bought the copyright
chat do you think I'm rich
hell no
I barely get by barely scraping by to do
this full time
hi Finn
yeah Jedi Jedi Survivor looks dope as
hell it really do
it looks dope
I haven't even talked to Thea
just like sometimes these fights are so
easy and other times they are like this
I've never even thought of this guy in
my life
do I need more decks or something
holy [ __ ]
foreign
[Music]
probably
okay
okay
that did not go well
why did my game look like really good
right now
kind of kind of out of nowhere
okay watch this watch this chat
okay look next time
I ran out of stamina
[Music]
[ __ ]
you're done
[ __ ] boy okay everybody watch this
I did that too freaking early man
no I did it in the wrong spot
oh my God I could not have [ __ ] up
more
I could not have done that worse
please
I just don't know how to use all these
[ __ ] tools man
Jesus Christ
I'm thinking though I'm thinking I'm
thinking
I don't I don't even know what's hitting
me but here we are getting hit by
something
come
that was risky as [ __ ] but here we are
I can't get all of them unfortunately
so I get hit by a couple at a time
come on
why is that other one being weird it's
like not doing anything
okay
Chad this is scuffed As It Gets
but we're here
okay that's annoying
uh yep
should I spam the spiral
chat loves the spiral I actually don't
want to risk getting hit by these
Keel with what tell me
I didn't have any more heels you
forehead
yo what up Peter how you doing man
all right listen I messed up hardcore on
the last one
heal with the pure force of will
excellent
right
right
I'm just not good at the UI
going through the UI and using the
spells that I want to use I'm just not
good at it I usually use big sword go
big Bonk Bonk you know
big sword go Bonk Bonk there we go
that was good
excuse magical heal I don't have any
I need a little bit more stamina
what is that
okay I just didn't trust it I just
didn't know what it was
okay here we go guys
I'm totally not gonna [ __ ] this up this
time
go into it
I broke them
I broke there I broke there
they just wouldn't stop rolling
oh my God
[Laughter]
that was just awesome
that was great
I've never seen that before I broke
their input reading they just like kept
rolling over and over again AI Panic
rolls
that was amazing
okay well we haven't done anything with
via yet but we have the option
later on uh
shoot
well let's go to the forge and Light It
Up
and then we gotta fight uh you know who
and you know who can I use Bernal am I
always allowed to use Bernal on a
on godskin Duo I feel like that's fair
listen to the sounds of flame
what do you think fia's body count is
the answer is yes
explains why wizard Mains only know how
to spam
dude true
what is your hardest boss except Melania
probably malacath I've always struggled
with malachith always
no matter what build I have no matter
how many times I fight him I did have a
I had a really good run against him last
um
when we were finishing off the drunk
stream
I had a no hit stage two on malakith
which was kind of insane so I'm getting
better against him
um but I [ __ ] hate Melania I think
she's trash
of course soldier of godric of course
I should probably put a water bowl out
there for her
not that I'm thinking of it
she's got her water bowl in here
but I can't keep the door open because I
don't want people to hear me
stream
I think I have stars of Ruin yeah
ratabase hurts your soul I don't really
ever have a well eldenbeast is always a
like just annoying
is Joy like in the new place I hope so
it's her first day here she spent the
night like I brought her home last night
um and it's her first day here so she's
getting used to it
but we went on a nice long walk around
the entire complex earlier today
she seemed to really like it
she got to look at some geese and some
swans
met a couple other dogs she got pets
from some old lady going to work
so I think she's had a good day and
basically she got home he ate and then
she's been asleep
all day and now she's hanging out on the
porch
so she's good
radagon his pimp slapped me around see I
like fighting against radagon and I can
sometimes go without getting hit against
ratagon
what breed is she she is a uh German
Shepherd Golden Retriever mix
so she's very smart
and very loyal
does she socialize well with other dogs
so what she does is she barks
at other dogs
when she's inside
so like if she sees a dog out a window
she'll bark at them but when she's
outside with them she won't bark and
she'll just be like she'll be chill
but she would never hurt another dog
ever
but sometimes she gets a little a little
feisty
with uh her her barking but that's it
yeah golden shepherd
a golden German
I think like she'll bark at other dogs
when she's inside because she's trying
to protect the area that she's in
because she's very protective
which is why I think she likes to hang
out on the porch so she can look at
what's going on
you know what I mean
German retriever
yeah I think that is just normal dog
behavior
so she's fine she's she's good with
other people and other dogs and
she loves people literally anybody she
is all about it
all about it
but dogs She's Gotta She's Gotta give
him a little sniff make sure they're lit
you know
I think I left her a bone out there so
she should be Totes My Goats fine
goat's fine I should probably go upgrade
huh well I can get a somber 9 out here
actually
before I go in
let me get to the door
foreign
yeah it's weird like it's it's the glass
right
it's weird when there's glass and she
like can't go to the dog I I don't know
how to put it
when she's behind a window or behind a
door she's just insanely protective
otherwise it's like she just doesn't
[ __ ] care
all I know is Joy's a good girl
you're a good girl
okay we got the nine and we picked up a
seven
so that's pretty good we can go do some
upgrades now
I should definitely upgrade the shield
as much as I can as well
now I think to at this point chat like
looking at our levels here should I just
be dumping into into intelligence like
do I want to get to 80 int at some point
I'll talk no show well I'm glad she
doesn't show I don't want her to do that
foreign with her talking but I don't
want her to hurt other dogs or other
people
hell no
[Music]
not really you have zero FPS so we want
to start doing FP yeah
okay
we're under leveled
you think so
int is not that great past 70 usually
stop at 70 then pump mine to 38 plus
as a mass flask fills of mine bar got it
mine intelligent Chad is lagging is that
normal is chat lagging
are you lagging chat
let me know I'm gonna let Joy back in
though
she's been out there a while
foreign
it's delayed where
press one
fast
where'd she go
I think she went to bed
yeah she was like I guess I'll come
inside
see that wasn't delayed at all that's
fine
you're delayed mister
look a little bit
plus you gotta think of the human error
human reaction time
yeah we're fine make sure you're caught
up to live that might help you as well
that may help you guys as well
how many likes are we at somebody tell
me quick
110
we gotta get to 200 soon
everybody like the stream immediately
now
like the stream like like the stream
like the Stream
do not like I should ban you for saying
that
oh wait so do we just not figure out
who did this because I didn't do her
questline at all
begging for likes equals automatic
dislike
oh my god dude I just thought about must
what you must be like in real life and I
just got so bored I fell asleep
holy [ __ ]
goodness
you're crazy
man
Trey is the best mod
wow I barely done anything in the round
table chat and everything's just like
here
kind of weird
hmm
hit okay
all right
we're spells
hmm
do we want something else here what am I
not using too much of
I think comet's great I don't like Shard
spiral chat I don't like it
when we have the common Azure with the
Terra Magicka it's kind of stupid it's
kind of useless so I'm gonna stop using
that
sorry to say I know some people in the
chat like it but I don't care
um
so I'm getting rid of that
I could go buy some other ones as well
let's go and see what else selin has in
her
interesting State here
um
where did ye flee my sweetings
my Apprentice okay
Scholars armament
is glintstone Comet Shard good
oh the turtle Pope we could go check him
out as well
stars of Ruin is okay
is that any of these I think we already
have it
Thomas shards weaker okay
you made her into a soccer ball I didn't
do it
as far as I know I don't really care
about any of these
let's go check uh Mr Turtle Pope
dog Pope
Turtle Pope
it's up there okay
comment is better so no Comet shard
did I have comment Shard on
common azure
and comment
uh why am I lost
weird
I'm thinking of putting back on
rocksling is that crazy of me
since we're using uh carrion or
Ronaldo's scepter
not tops is dumb
Ron Grace
I swear to God
some of y'all need to like
think about
what you have chatted before you press
enter
you do
it's not a lot of y'all but some of
y'all need to start doing that
it's a good practice to have you're
tarnished I welcome that's racist how
did he know I was tarnished
heal
I would say if you find it unless this
is the internet no one thinks dude shrew
you know what I could think about is
that you typing a comment or in the chat
probably helps with the algorithm so
just type something stupid all the time
it's fine
ooh is karian Greatsword good
I am not killing the turtle Pope stand
that is ridiculous
you guys know I did uh I did
it was one of the interesting
discoveries in Elden ring and I really
found Muriel's uh
dialogue after you kill him to be super
interesting
and I did that in a video and I showed
his dialogue and I even apologized for
killing him before showing the dialogue
because almost no one's done that right
no one kills this Turtle it's it's too
hard to do but I put it in the video and
I had some guy
make a comment
that said
what did he say it was it was like I was
Politically Incorrect for even putting
it in the video or something like that
it was like the most Reddit comment I've
ever seen in my life like he said I
think he literally said I should be
canceled for even showing the dialogue
from that
I should be canceled for killing a
turtle
like in the game or something I read it
and I was just like wow this person
literally doesn't have a life
crazy man
crazy okay so you guys say this is good
or not I did not pay attention
I did not pay attention dog
beep okay I'm getting it
and I'm equipping it because I think
Rock sling's not going to be that great
now to be totally honest with you
to be totally honest with you
moonblade's better how do I get the moon
blade
we'll keep this for now that's a
comically large water bottle
it tells me because I drink one of these
a day right and it tells me the time
here
the time
so I'm pretty much on par
for the day
like 1pm I should be here 3 P.M I should
be here 5 p.m I should be here does that
make sense it's good for me okay
shut your [ __ ] mouth
how many times I got to say that to
y'all a day
I feel like I say that a lot
hmm okay
the dragon outside the Moonlight altar
oh yeah okay Bet
yeah I got an idea why don't you shut
your dumb big dumb mouth hole
yeah I have carrying slicer so this will
give us a little bit more range
you mad bro I'm [ __ ] furious Claudio
a furious man
I'm so angry you got me all riled up bro
is this the reaction you wanted
okay I'm done all right where am I going
what am I doing uh back over Yonder
do the Moonlight altar skip is that a
thing
silence your face yo
I God I hate I hate you oh I hate these
guys I hate them man
they're trash
y'all don't tell me about Frost pots oh
I can't use this yet I have to enter the
fight don't I I have to fight him at
least once
go away
okay this isn't gonna work
hmm
all right
[Music]
I am not happy about that damage output
on that guys
I am not happy about that at all
[Music]
I guess it's okay
I don't think it really Buffs that much
I'm upset
come on man you already hit me once
okay
I had a plan and now it's ruined
gaming
gaming
oh
no
excellent
I have things on my brain
laughs
I I wanted to wait till he did that
right there
okay that wasn't that bad for a first
try
that wasn't that bad
Perry hit oh dude I keep forgetting I
could Parry his things can I holy [ __ ]
you're right
I almost want to fight him again without
Bernal
I keep forgetting
that here should have thrown the ax
I'm so glad I didn't stream God of War
I am so happy I didn't
guys where's Bernal he's not even an
option
where'd he go
do something in particular for that
okay
I did not kill Bernal
why would I do that
[ __ ] guy
why don't why aren't I using this
[ __ ]
[Music]
you have to interact with him first no
shot
he got stuck on the ledge
I'm mad about that happening
oh my God I'm gaming right now
oh I even went in there all big
that's embarrassing I'm embarrassed
I'm embarrassed
[ __ ]
and they Dodge
that's sad
he's there at the side of Grace close no
he's not
he's definitely we're at the door that I
keep trying to go at for sure
unless he somehow changes positions on
where he can be summoned
wow
currently gaming
[Music]
it's not the wrong site GB I know it for
a fact
unless he does have different positions
that I don't know of
but I know you can summon them where I
tried to summon them for sure
because we just did this like the other
day
honestly I could just keep my distance
and Parry their fireballs
that they keep spamming at me
okay if he moved then I'll have to find
him in another spot
look at these parries
Harry hotter out here
foreign
could not have been worse
uh to the right last door and down the
stairs
to the right last store down the stairs
he did move positions he moved to a
different door why does he go to a
different door
is there like
a reason
it happens
did you parry the weight off him I don't
know about that
so I go this way and to the right
I don't think you have to talk to him in
volcano Manor
it's my knowledge
okay I can't go right here
oh my god well
was there a down did I go down the
correct hallway or did I need to go
where I was going before
I can never [ __ ] remember where this
site is ever
it it always blinks my mind
for some reason
I'll just go down here
okay I'm going down the stairs and to
the left
full canal
chat
foreign
okay
oh I gotta jump down
right
isn't there a ledge like right there or
something I can't remember
am I getting trolled right now
wait
wait
y'all can even see me going through the
chat right now
y'all see it bro
jump down the stairs behind you
and down again to follow the path okay
here
right
right
so I was getting trolled
well
what's [ __ ] new man
pick up the item
holy [ __ ]
now
this is why I can never find this
oh my God bro
I'm getting annoyed
oh
okay I'll go left this time
these guys are so stupid man
oh my God
they're so dumb
[ __ ]
you see the tornado jumped towards it
and it'll send you flying amalekhead I'm
just trying to get to this [ __ ]
stupid side of Grace that you guys want
me to use
just kill him why would I do that when I
can run past them if I knew where I was
going
because I'm just not I don't know where
I'm going
because this area is always this I don't
I don't get it
I I don't know where to go
you keep dying bro no [ __ ] [ __ ] man
no kidding
wow
incredible insight
and super helpful hey I found it
Jesus
you guys suck sometimes I'll tell you
that right now
sometimes man
you guys smell like you should be taking
a shower he's not even here
the whole point was to have Bernal
near the door
oh oh [ __ ] hell
I know we didn't hurt Bernal right
no shot
[Music]
now I'm just confused
hmm
oh
my God
there's your Perry baby
let's go femi
I appreciate that man
oh [ __ ] I'm dead
that attack is so stupid I'll say it
I said it
dumb and stupid
whatever
good to see you femi and welcome bro
good to have you
dude sane sleeping pots are good for
these guys is like saying Frost pots are
good against Melania
like I know I got it
I I see you
if they both do it at the same time then
that's just kind of unlucky I was stuck
in an animation and I'm dead all right
I'm not having a great time
go talk to him once I don't remember
having to talk to Bernal I really don't
but I guess I could
also he's not gonna be in volcano Manor
now
wow that was [ __ ] annoying
hmm
that was annoying
um
use bleed pipe
[Music]
okay Tanis is in there
I don't think I haven't even been in
volcano Manor
have I [ __ ]
you can Parry his sword by the way yeah
I'm sure I can dude I'm sure I can I'm
I'm sure that'll make a giant difference
why is chat so weird the last two days
how can I get in a volcano Manor
normally
uh
is that where this is
I'm gonna go in the front door
[ __ ] it
yeah what what is chat's fascination
with pots
I don't even think I've crafted an item
in this game
foreign
maybe you're the weirdo
right it's my fault
definitely
you should be at the Round Table
Bernal has never been at the round table
ever right
I don't think so
because pots rule
bernal's never at the round table at any
point
I've got a fascination with pot but an
Aiden Eldon ring
exactly wait I can't get in here I don't
have the key
so I guess I have to go to the shack
unless she gives me the key here
excellent
she's uh eating Reichard right now
oh and his Shack gotcha
anyone in here nope
I don't know why anyone would be in here
at this point because their leader is
dead and their other leader is eating
eating him
so uh
I guess we'll go here
this means I've already talked to him
though maybe I didn't talk talk to him
since when does he die
for what
what happened
huh
I'm now I'm just like confused
holy [ __ ]
you never talk to him I guess not
that's an l
hmm
this game has so many twists and turns
in it
so we're gonna have to fight them
without Bernal
because he killed the serpent
I bet if I talk to him even if I kill
reichardt it wouldn't matter
okay
I guess we have to get good
oh God all right
um
well
here we go
time to get good boys
currently getting good
that timing was stupid
get [ __ ] idiot
oh my God
it's it's so funny
I'm laughing about it at this point
how I just get karma'd
right away
thanks
there's one
foreign
no
[Music]
music change
foreign
this this [ __ ] game man I swear to
God
thank you
this [ __ ] game is so stupid
no
no
stay over there
just jump up good
throw something at me do it
[Music]
I don't want to waste it there we go
that's what we wanted right there dead
[ __ ] dead
I'm doing it
okay
Dom shouldn't have done that
it's a waste
um
I'm an idiot I threw no we can still do
it we can still do it
just use these until their health is
gone yep
yep
we got slicer if we need it
I can do this man
come on gaming
[ __ ] your sleep pots chat
[ __ ] them your sleep pots are trash
I almost threw that though I did I
almost threw it
[ __ ] your sleep pots
I'm gonna drink out of my excessively
big water jug
this build's pretty fun not gonna lie
all right you guys said I need more mind
and I couldn't agree more
I'm pumping mind a bit
textbook GG
now malacath
question
can I can I Parry
his fire attacks in stage two
and throw him back in his face
thank you femi
Sam you know what chat needs more mind
just like my character does
through dude
we went over this yesterday a little bit
ever since I started doing this sorcerer
build we've had way more back seaters in
chat than I did when I go like big Bonk
way more backseating
crazy
it is what it is but I just found it to
be kind of funny
you can if you beat Bernal
oh you can't okay I can only do that
with the Blasphemous claw
because big Bonk people don't care
dude
right
you are a self-admitted
neophyte when it comes to a wizard build
everyone just trying to help
what the [ __ ] is a Neo fight
what did you just call me
huh
are you okay
Jesus
[Music]
neophyte is not noob
[Music]
oh
foreign
for ignorant
really
interesting
so I'm being ignorant for not listening
to what chat wants me to do
because it's my build and my stream so
that makes me ignorant huh
interesting
very interesting
no I haven't made a video on the dragons
there's already a bunch of good videos
on the dragons
I don't think I could go any further
with it
a person who is new or subject or a
belief
okay
hmm
hmm
hmm
I mean I am new to Mage builds this is
my first mage build I've ever done
but
how am I ignorant for wanting to do a
mage build the way that I want to
on my own stream
and then I do ask questions sometimes
I'll ask like should I use this should I
use that
but what I'm like in a fight saying
something like
you need uh what was this as far as
Wizards go you're a noob okay
it's fine
I just said that whatever
all I'm saying is chat's being weird
ever since I started doing a mage build
it it's been it's been strange
I'll admit it
should I level my endurance
look I should
because you need endurance to cast
spells
maybe decks
or is endurance not that important
dude they aren't even haters like
they'll keep saying like we're just
trying to help when yeah I get it until
you're a dick about it bro
I don't know
jellyfish Shield
mm-hmm
people only like to see the most optimal
boarding on cheese when it comes to
spell builds I think that's the best way
to put it
Dex is minor all right
it only comes in effect around 40. yeah
we're not getting to that
uh
only if you want to chain spells
honestly I think we're casting enough
like it's fine what what do you think um
should I should I get to like 30 mind
something like that
should be okay with that we can also go
Respec if we really want to
um
radagon's icon yes
can you explain the going glowing skulls
the ones that have runes in them
I think there's skulls that have runes
in them
very colder
we should uh definitely do that
all right I'm gonna do something stupid
here chat
it doesn't reach come on
come on there we go
that didn't turn out to be stupid at all
it's incredible
that was great that was great
wow
sheesh I got put in timeout because Jake
doesn't know the meaning of a word I
didn't know the meaning but maybe it's
because you called me something like
that man are you [ __ ] stupid you must
be a gifted member holy [ __ ] man
learn some like personal skills social
skills
man bro some people dude are just
[ __ ] weird
yeah I think only the first time I
really worked there
okay man dude you must be like a [ __ ]
kid there's no way you're an adult doing
this [ __ ]
foreign
no
holy [ __ ]
foreign
wow man first try you ever thought you'd
see it on the Stream
holy [ __ ]
you ever thought I'd first try malacath
on this stream
the amount of hours we've spent on this
guy
the amount of hours
grinding away on malachath to just get
him first try feels really good man
holy [ __ ] oh my God
wow bro
damn dude
foreign
I do think I've gotten really good at
stage two stage one we kind of cheesed
obviously
we definitely cheese that there
dude I'm not even mad I'm not mad at
anybody Chad
but when someone's Throwing Shade in the
chat like
I can't just you know say nothing I
guess I could but [ __ ] dude
so unnecessary
[ __ ] video game
no I'm not mad
well it is then
you'll be Elden Lord yet
okay
um
mm-hmm
Perry hotter believing in-game would be
hard
how many builds do you have
done a lot of strength builds
a lot
a lot
I can't can't even tell you dozens and
dozens of times
yeah that that's where I'm always like
maybe I should just ignore people in the
chat who are clearly just being dicks
but I want them to know they're being a
dick so that maybe they can learn how to
not be a dick you know what I mean but I
think trying to tell someone on the
internet that they're being that way is
pretty much impossible
they they're never going to believe that
they're being an [ __ ] ever
no I've never played Hollow Knight
before I've been asked that a lot
recently
so there's our 30 mind
what are you guys think in here
that's all we got so I'll ask that next
time
soldier of godric run we already did
that
in our um 100 run
why'd you time that out Trey
that was a fine message
Rick Rowling gets timeouts that's not
Rick Rolling bro that's
no Rick is Soldier of godric Trey that
we we did an entire playthrough of
our 100 run is as soldier of godric
and that was awesome that was a lot of
fun
or Rick
you can go back and watch it if you want
Logan I think that was before you were
here
very odd comma placement the comma has
to be there
damn it Trey
I'm I'm sorry British
personally
but the 100 run is on uh
is on the channel
worst mod ever no
mistakes happen
did you post yep it's on it's on the one
of the playlists should be the 100
playlist
I need to remember to repost the Dark
Souls 1 playthrough as well
I think people be interested in that I'm
getting phone calls
like a [ __ ] hold on chat I'm
muting I'm gonna listen to him
[Music]
[Music]
okay sorry guys that's about the movers
who are gonna bring the couch
they're giving me an estimate on how
much that'll cost so I got to call them
back after stream later
okay
what do I do here guys
I think we know what to do here
we have one chance at this
one
here we go
Spirit but it's a loss
onto eternity
damn it chat
he broke out of it oh wait I can Parry
[ __ ] man you thought well until now
hey this this won't be that bad
he won't be that bad I forgot I can
Parry I am Perry hotter and I forgot how
to Parry
damn it
well
it's because he's a humanoid and he fell
over weird or something
nice
I think I'm gonna slice him up
you fought well until now
I don't think you can move the comet
I was I've been trying to move the
comment and it won't move I don't know
if that was changed or anything
or I'm doing it incorrectly
uh I just got [ __ ] up
I'm a little worried about it
I'm a little worried about it boys oh
oh no
foreign
I'm keeping my distance man [ __ ] this
guy
somehow that's periable
I'm embarrassed
did he already heal chat
[ __ ]
okay it's variable but kinda
he did heal he did
nice
why is there one little bitch-ass Arrow
so dumb
hello
I'm nervous
actually a cool fight God knows
that was kind of cool
like the a mage fight that was actually
kind of sick
Harry Potter is an actual w
ow okay what can we do against
Godfrey and horlu huh
there's
I guess we can [ __ ] him up right at the
beginning huh
well I'm at the beginning
I don't know what do you guys think what
should I level now
35 Vigor 30 mine 10 endurance 10
strength
15 decks 60 inch
if we want to use like Moon spells we go
80 inch but I don't know if we want to
use that
um
slicer spam that's kind of what I was
thinking
need more mind maybe we go for 40 vigor
I think that's the best one
I've been trying to avoid vigor
um for the most part
but I think we're gonna be okay like
this
you should swap to carrion Glenstone
staff why
this staff is Boost all oh this is for
Full Moon huh
this one
I'd have to upgrade it and everything I
think we're good we're doing plenty of
damage
wouldn't you say
good luck against paragon
all right holy [ __ ]
I might just slice him up
who's carrying sword sorceries
Ronnie's Dark Moon is 68 inch
hmm I mean we're already level 100.
that's a minor okay
um I'm still thinking of what to do here
what is this
should we use them I've never used him
in this fight
ever
personally
I didn't even know he was here that's
interesting
I mean yeah it's chabreary sure
oh man I didn't know he was here
that's cool
good all right all right all right
yeah he must be here because we have the
frenzied flame yep for sure
well
here we go
so very different fight
okay that was freaking sick
holy moly
I'm thinking to slice him up boys
if I was casting too much
no I for how was he not stage two dude
I think we're doing L damage because we
summoned in shibiri
they do it takes more damage to kill
than when he uses summon
I'm curious how much damage we're doing
without him
just out of pure curiosity I'm not going
to summon them this time
slice and dice baby
I'm gonna try this one more time we'll
do this
outside the door
as y'all yell at me to do constantly
am I too far away
let's find out
sure am
come on baby
get a little bit closer baby
come on baby
there it is
so much fun to do
foreign
dude I keep forgetting
oh
there we go
slice them up boys
that hurt a lot
I am gaming currently
foreign
he got me
he didn't get me
not yet baby
[Music]
okay I didn't die somehow
that's an opportunity
foreign
that was fun that was actually fun as a
sorcerer
man bro wow
we had to game it up there boys let's go
40 vigor
and increase our mind a little bit more
let's go baby
oh man
confirmed in is better than strength
not that bro
I don't know about that bro where's my
doggy I'm gonna go pee real quick and
pet my dog
I'll try and get her back out here I'll
be right back
forefathers one and all
well Witness
hello
hello
no no
all the time you know
okay
okay come on up
girl
good girl
wait what happened
I heard something
twits to give it a great rune
let's go baby thank you twisted
what are you doing
Bingo Bubba
you're being good bubba you don't hang
out with
hang out right she's a good girl
you got itchy ear
yeah
thank you twisted and that's make sure
you say thank you which I think you did
thank you
dogs have shells right right this is a
turtle
you need a separate dog camp
nah
are you a good girl
you go back on porch and go on porch
okay
I'm back
okay
we're back
yes chat you can see my feet you can see
my feet
my feet
are in view
for free
wash your hands why would I do that I
have a clean dick
how tall are you like five nine five ten
on a good day
if I'm feeling tall if I sleep well I
can get to like 5 10.
all right
y'all know what we had to do okay has
been yeah it's from asthma gold
I think it's funny and a great answer
[Music]
um
did we already get The Medallion from
um
yeah we did so we just have to go get
this Medallion the asthma gold classic
absolutely
oh granny
became an Elden Lord I missed that I am
very sorry
I'm sorry I missed that and I'm a stupid
idiot
and now I'm going the wrong way
I really appreciate that thank you I did
not see that I was going pee
I appreciate it
thank you thank you
thank you for reminding me too Stan
[Music]
is she up on the thing yet
she's laying down on the floor
please Do's night stuff
that's not a bad idea actually
put on bernal's Armor yeah I definitely
have the
the endurance to do that definitely not
but your hand is dirty my hand's not
dirty
did you wash your dick
um
okay
you drinking enough water
yeah
we good
we good
it's probably the reason I had to go pee
why I'm inside Bernal and okay
sometimes I need to read the chat before
I read it out loud
thoughts
yeah I'm I should probably do that
I am super strong holy [ __ ]
please no dear me
I haven't a clue no secrets lie with me
not a one
do not think do you
you must yes we'll try Melania
I love Melania she's the best she's the
best boss
ever man she's so fun to fight and
um so well designed and
you know
um super fun dodgeable attacks
I I'm I love her she's so cool
yep
we'll we'll do Moog first I lifted the
wrong [ __ ] medallion
Chad I'm I'm not even upset about the
waterfowl the waterfowl is not even the
concern and I I I'm not I'm not gonna go
further
I'm just going back down
this word chat yells about for 10
minutes about freezing pots bro I know
I mean the other day we did watch a
video a 20 minute video on why Melania
is not
well designed
and I could not agree with that video
more
but uh you know it's all right
and next time I'll try poop pots those
are actual things
hmm
it is a secret stream now I had to take
down that uh the stream before I moved
he got copyright struck
from me playing Gwen's theme from Dark
Souls 1.
you all believe that
so I deleted and the copyright strikes
gone but I'm just like what the [ __ ]
it's dark souls Gwen's theme
copyrighted now apparently
I didn't even know that
now I do
how does that get copyrighted I don't
know
I didn't see the company that
copyrighted it
personally did not see it
I was just like oh really and then I
just deleted it because it was kind of a
weird stream anyway
it's okay
yep
everybody blame uh
Taylor Swift it's her fault
all right guys
why do I always get lost in here
oh [ __ ] you
L Taylor Swift
since when is there a rune bear here
I don't think I've ever even seen bears
in this area
ball [ __ ]
what's my health at I'm curious
know what it say
I couldn't see
no
where is she I couldn't even see my help
I think it said three
lay down deer
do whatever you want to do
you know whatever you want to do
I've never seen the Bears over there
I've learned something new every time I
play this game man I really do
did she go to bed did she go that way I
didn't see
she loves the bedroom bro
she loves it over there
hi Meg how are you
that's my sister
new apartment
Joy's getting used to it
okay maybe I do have to sweep around
over this way
I do okay stick
yep
there we go
I want to know the Rune Bears workout
routine
is that the goal of every like lifter is
to look like a rune bear
they are pretty big
huge in fact
[Music]
oh yeah I know all about the sanguine
Noble
foreign
oh [ __ ] I'm over here
all right do you guys want Melania or
Moog first
I think we should do Moog first
personally but
I know y'all are uh
pretty opinionated here
the last couple days about stuff
Moog moggy
seeing more moogs than melanius
let me get rid of Anastasia here
I'm gonna Bopper
where's she at bro
this is a problem
I always think that's this
that was a bigger problem
we're working on it
she's insane
I I love how she gets eye frames while
she's jumping in the air
and just can't get hit
isn't that great
isn't that great
and now I'm all the way back here
yeah I first tried malekith and I just
died to Anastasia
antasia and it's you know what nobody
cares
nobody cares bro
you look like you ride
what
oh we could fight placidusacks first
I just don't want to go back and forth
on that fight
yet
oh no I don't ride motorcycles now
you'll never catch me on one either
ever
ever
you will never catch me on a motorcycle
that [ __ ] dangerous
okay let's go to mode Let's go to mode
I offer you an accord why do you guys
think Melina doesn't just kill us
she probably can't like she's she's not
in a position where she can actually do
that yet if I had to guess
you know what I mean
really
I really am good at fighting Moog
it's true
I hate her I hate I hate this person
she has become the bane of my existence
the last two weeks
what is this damage
stop it
oh
there we go
there's our plus 10 by the way
which I already had before
just didn't pick up because I'm uh you
know
a little silly
she scales with your level
okay
still a lot of damage
tea bagger nah I'd probably get canceled
or something
let's not
let's just not do that
weakest strength user no that was from
our Rune Roulette Challenge
tenfold
we already had our weakest build
I I I'm dead are you [ __ ] kidding me
are you actually serious
foreign
[Music]
foreign
how are you
oh God
I love the Aimbot on those [ __ ]
things
Chad I'm mad
oh no
okay
get your Graven Mass what's that
and more Graces I mean did you see me
literally directly outside of where I
needed to be and I jumped off a cliff
instead of went through the cave where I
would have gotten a Grace in an area
that I wanted to be in
and now I have to fight this [ __ ] guy
because you know
[ __ ] happens
it comes from that way right
that way
there we go
okay
okay
why is he RP walking me
you don't have any heels bro
nice back stuff
foreign
the [ __ ] bug bro
where is it
[ __ ] you
thank you
[Laughter]
yeah it was Overkill I don't care
he almost cheesed me
[Laughter]
yep I comma desert a bug
who's seen magic Talisman like the one
you already have they stack with each
other in the tower of the Frozen River
Frozen River so back there somewhere
um
oh we should get bubble protection for
milk let me just get to the grace
outside of his door and then we'll go
get all that stuff
if you're a member give me a giga in
chat if you're cool with that
and use the emote giga
because it's cool
I don't see enough giggas
[Music]
okay there's one
nice nice
that's the kind of gigas I like to see
why not just deserve him is that still
gonna work because I've seen that clip
when the game first came out print
should we just do that
I'll give it a try if I die then we'll
go get all the stuff
are you liking your place I really like
it here Ethan
Joy has joined us
I think she's getting used to it it'll
take a minute though
he has a very long lineup can try to
reserve him
don't know if you can we'll see
we're gonna give it a shot though
I do have the unlimited FP for 15
seconds
or is the Canon reason still unknown
if why America shattered the Alden ring
there's nothing definitive
but we have really good guesstimates of
why she did
could be that her sons died
could be she's trying to get back at the
the greater will
maybe she's trying to weaken the greater
will in a way that she can
could be
[Music]
um
I don't know
lots of other reasons
but do we know for sure not yet
there you go phosphorus
all right let's give this a shot
you think her shattering the Elven ring
was a mistake can you imagine like
whenever we meet her in a DLC she's like
I didn't mean to do it I was trying to
repair it and I broke
can you imagine
I'd be out of nowhere
what is your opinion on all the ages in
Eldon ring
like how old they are or all of the
time frames if that's what you mean
America made an oopsie
all right here we go
oh no
that was a nope
[Music]
not even sure what I just got hit by
foreign
one more time because we still get the
long run up and I think I could have
done it a little bit earlier
I think I coulda
or it got nerfed and we can't
damn it he's too far
so good against Moog
who would you rather have on your team
chat Moog or me
easiest answer in your life
foreign
I'm not looking at chat right now but I
bet it was a lot of Jake's
that was my fault
pain
all right we're gonna dupe this out
somehow
is
okay uh yeah let's uh let's go get the
the
stuff
yeah
yeah is he resistant now maybe yeah
maybe maybe we go get the blood bubble
let's go get the bubble guys
it's is it this church right here I
think
all right
we bout to find out
remember to Parry oh that's right there
are some like the blood the blood can
yeah yeah
the blood can
what time is it Clockwork 127. nice
guys I would like everyone to know
that with the settings I changed from
yesterday
we dropped 47 000 frames total
which is kind of nuts today we have
dropped 222.
I think I fixed the settings hopefully
the stream has looked really good
to know
hopefully it's looking good
I had to I just had to change some
settings around you know how it'd be
you guys know how it'd be
there's a sacred tear
mm-hmm
whoa
right
holy [ __ ] that attack comes in quick
okay wait wait
okay that's so cool actually
why did I do that
get
nope
nope
why don't why do I keep doing that
I could have ended it right there
my God I keep accidentally flicking over
Chad I'm gonna throw this aren't I okay
I didn't
stream's looking great honestly let's go
all right we got that
that's big for us that's big
um
did we just go try again
honestly yes
I think we just go try again
foreign
oh wait I gotta put it on I'm an idiot
well
hopefully this doesn't kill me
I thought there was a Grace up there for
some reason
there is not
uh
okay that's not what I wanted to do I
already forgot that's how my brain works
guys
I get distracted
no I don't have the moon blade
not yet
you guys are real big on night sorceries
I like the Spells I'm using
so I'm gonna keep using them
now okay okay
we got this
all right guys
my favorite build ever is ruins
Greatsword
easy
just want to get the most time out of it
you know
Thrice
let's go
that seemed a bit cringe
so what I did used to be able to kill
him right
or maybe I just need more in
this takes too long to cast
again I'm cringing
no I thought I had time
[ __ ]
I do keep forgetting to Parry I don't
think that's gonna make a huge
difference but
I should do that you're right
reichardt sword op right yeah I really
like using uh the serpent Hunter as well
yeah he heals a lot bro
I mean it's a good start
Baldwin
Thrice
man if only it lasted a little bit
longer dude
I'm gonna comment them
foreign
foreign
I'm so focused right now if you couldn't
tell
and there it is
nice
yup first try totally
I'm so bad
mullaney's gonna be that easy right
let's go fight the dragon
go fight the dragon
oh my God okay we gotta go sell a whole
bunch of [ __ ] actually let's go
all right guys it's gonna be fine you
know it's gonna be fine it's gonna be
it's gonna be it's gonna be okay it's
gonna be fine
Melania first try easy you know the last
time I heard that in my own chat I was
fighting her for six hours
somebody said that before I thought the
first try on her I'm not kidding
I'm not
they said that man
I was surprised
but they said it that wasn't even a plus
10. let's go
Melania will stay still for the Azure
really will she
what were you guys saying I should do
here like 35 mind right
yeah I'll change my physic back as well
no
okay
what should I be doing then
oh you're saying no to her dodging not
the mind
okay
and then
just all mined let's just do 40 mind
[ __ ] it
[ __ ] it dude
all right place to do sacks
how's uh how's our strategy against
placidusacks
with the commodizer
68 for frostbite Moon I think we're okay
without it I'm not really I don't really
like the Moon spells is that weird
use Rock sling oh shoot I forgot to
change my physic
should I put on Rock sling
oh and you're saying spiral
okay
okay
got it
uh
what should I use stores half HP sure
I'm not real big on the carrying
Greatsword
to be honest with you
just Knight Comet that [ __ ] Moon spells
are debuffed not main damage
oh that's true
you're right
um
roxling is best spell it carried me in
the game bro all the way through even
plaster do sacky
I'll have it as an option
I'm going to change
you know what I'm gonna go with the
Strat that you guys were screaming at me
about
we're gonna try the spiral against
placidusacks because we can be right up
in his guts the entire time
and we can just Spam it after using the
physic
oh God
yes he has multiple asses as well as
multiple heads
actually I don't think he has multiple
asses oh
almost died
no he doesn't have multiple asses
this game needs more spells are you sure
about that
oh you guys all saying spiral because
it's good in PvP
oh man
oh man
all right we got this though
is Magic not that good anymore
uh-oh
um
well
kind of wish I didn't do that now
oh
I don't even know we could reach that
far
why did that come in delayed bro [ __ ] I
thought it just wasn't gonna happen
it's a pretty oh boy
it doesn't reach pain
all right guys time to slice them up
I am definitely not gonna use spiral
again
excellent it's trash
we're gonna have to change all these
[Music]
all right
I have quite literally never seen him
jump into that attack before
there's a ghost behind you
ah now it's dead
think about that all right let's change
this [ __ ] up
[Music]
foreign
it's gone not using it
but these are the
the things you wanted me to use
carrying slicer against plastic do sacks
is [ __ ] trash I'm sorry
um
let's try the arc
I think that'll be good against him
go farm this one bubble trumpet for two
hours and the class to do sex will be
easy
no
I don't have the good bow Miro I have
the normal basic though
slicer's op and PVP yeah it's really
fast
but we're fighting a giant dragon and
not another player
arcs for trash mobs
hmm
I think it'll be good
No I barely ever use Rune arcs
used with caution trips
passion
where do I get meteor shower
astel
roxling kind of sucks
oh wait he's down
this is somewhat going well
I need to never talk ever
okay
[Music]
excellent
chat I don't like the ark
I think we have learned that the ark is
not very good
thoughts
get him
y'all see what I'm cooking up right
I'm definitely cooking something up
right now
of course
just let me cook boys
I'm out here gaming right now
just let me cook
three nukes
yeah he's not dying fast
damn it
he's gonna disappear
dang it
he baited me boys
let's go
patience is key
let's go
just had to stay patient take my time
use my resources correctly
Dodge all his attacks
hit him when there's an opening and then
you win you just do all that and then
you're fine
right
man that's crazy all right
what's level
let's level
and then I gotta take joy to go pee
JoJo you wanna go pee pee
she does hello
you go pee
you [ __ ]
look at this good girl you good sit yes
look he's a good girl
okay we'll be back in like a minute okay
uh
y'all come up with what I should put
points into I'll be right back
do you need to go pee you wanna go pee
okay
we're back
he acquired
what are y'all talking about
mind stamina and mind I got a snack
decks for casting speed stamina I think
stamina's endurance is what we want to
go
half stamina half mind
we have 40 mind I think we're good on
the mine part
but I think endurance
can definitely help us
we're going with that
yeah 40 mind I believe is definitely
plenty it has to be Chad how many likes
are we at
am I am I going to be disappointed when
I find out
204 okay we got two hundo
that's good that's good
that's the goal every stream to get too
Hondo
I'm okay with that
I'm good with it
miners five
shut up
oh you don't want to go up there okay
he's right there
is rising you gotta like the stream bro
have to
Billy if you don't
all right
ladies and gentlemen it is time
you know what for
the Haley tree
um
did I really not pick up
any other Grace besides this one
man
[Music]
that's really edgy of you dot
your name is a literal punctuation mark
are you [ __ ] kidding me
and your profile picture is just blacked
out
it's real edgy bro
super cool
everyone can we get a cap for what the
[ __ ] Don just said
I might need a cap on that one
I don't even know if YouTube knows what
cap means
yep
there you go no cap
why do these bars just fall apart
recently
what's your strategy to kill her before
she kills me
ah
this is a Korean Royal Style
foreign
you like that plan chat
I haven't done any Ronnie's Quest no
none of it
foreign
ly the best gamer in the room and it's
not even close
mainly because it's just me and my dog
to say I panicked would be an
understatement
Jesus Christ
I had a shield and everything
didn't use it I have range with spells
didn't use it
foreign
Joy loves the bedroom bro
at least I hit the skip
sorry I needed to like zone out for a
second
that made me mad
why is my luck weird it's like every
time I speak something stupid happens
if I gasp myself up at all
I get immediately humbled
what's up with that
I feel like it's a little weird at this
point you know
why would I level up Arcane on this
character do you have a reason for that
or are you just saying it
okay
foreign
why is Glenstone Arc so bad
what's up with that
what did they do to it
I guess it's just like a beginning spell
like what you do at the start of your
journey
I got that one
is Ark not a starting spell [ __ ]
foreign
it's good in PvP I'm sure it is but man
Arc is meant for crowds that's it
all right
fair enough point
let's not get grabbed here
it's not the spell I mean it literally
didn't do any damage to that
Archer
so
I don't know what you're talking about
at least Harry
hotter looks good while he's playing you
know I mean
maybe it's you
and I could tell you're like a twitch
viewer mainly because you asked me if I
like forced in earlier which was already
like a major l
just a sign
how do I get up there now without her
instantly killing me
whatever
cool
yeah now I actually can't go up there
is this even moog's robes
I don't think so this is all rich
aldriches
something like that
all right
foreign
God
why are they so annoying man
I'll never understand
hold on I got my snackies
you know
nom nom nom
okay
who these teleporters are made by
wonder how they came to be
[ __ ] this area okay
not moog's robe you have
you half you half the butt one
of the two go to Round Table and OG to
the two fingers Jake Dawn
I think you slapped your keyboard
and pressed enter
what did you say
I mean even changing that word Don your
sentence still doesn't make sense
foreign
also I don't think you get moog's armor
from the Round Table
which I think was in that sentence
somewhere up in there
oh God
really
oh well yeah I turned it into Enya right
you're right
true
I'm thinking of sand green Noble not
Moog
you're right
sanguine
which I believe I have because I killed
that dude
should I put that on is it better
actually don't even know what this does
yep
foreign
sorcery
nothing well I'm not using thorns
so
this do be pretty drippy as well
what are we thinking now my legs look
kind of weird
I'm gonna go back this this is fine it's
it's mainly for looks
Austin Andrews
thanks for becoming a great room man
good to have you appreciate it
thank you thank you thank you
I need to start saying this when people
become members
welcome to the agency
that's what our uh our community is
called anyone who didn't know
welcome to the agency chat if you
remember you're part of the agency
oh well he retracted his message pain
cringe now you're just one of those
people who thinks everything is cringe
it's not it's fun
okay
you know it should be fun
imagine if you had Giga Chad dot kind of
cringe that you don't
foreign
the load up on that thing is insane
millennia
Trey
let's go
thanks man
thanks for the five gifted members
if you got a gifted from Trey make sure
to say thank you
should start rolling out
God damn it dot got one
pain
of course he did
[Music]
huh
dovey's in the chapter Trey
yep I should be parrying
why is that animation so [ __ ] long
where you like accidentally press a
flash that you don't have and he does
that forever
that was clean
do it again I keep forgetting
look at me go
damn I'm so good
oh only work for one I'm dead
thank you
I don't know why it turned into Mickey
Mouse sir
now she shoots multiple
so I can't really grab him
see
she's kind of spamming too
foreign
oh my God
foreign
I should have known man
I'm thinking like no way it'll just hit
the ground right in front of me
it's it's a [ __ ] Bow Dog it's gonna
track you
that was a whoopsie on my part
that was a whoopsie
because this feels quick to me Matt
it's the only way I know how to do it I
played too long doing it like this
foreign
not as nice
foreign
that is nice
[ __ ]
okay nice okay watch
I mean that's that's the bow we uh thing
we want
I think that'll be big for us because I
had the normal bow
now we got that bow
nice
GG
get a shield that blocks I mean I'm
literally countering the [ __ ]
I'm taking spells and throwing them back
at her I think that's pretty sick
definitely endurance okay
here we go guys
I
am Melania
blade of mcclellan's
let's throw that on yeah okay cool
for physical attacks I think it does
Parry physical attacks as well
and it does block physical attacks I
just don't do it
yeah I have Godfrey's icon
I have it on already
and I have never known
defeat
I have never known
defeat
okay so my plan I have in my head is
when Melania goes stage two
and she does the thing
where she blooms into a beautiful flower
that is where I comment Azure her life
thoughts
with the physic with everything
other than that we player normal as we
do
chat was telling me it can do physical
attacks
glitch Melania
nah
it can
okay
get some Frost pots
I [ __ ] hate this place
[Laughter]
oh my God bro I it's so pretty but this
place sucks
it's so annoying
I honestly have just been picking up
talismans that Chad tells me to
sometimes I listen to them and sometimes
I don't
depends on my mood
Bowl stop
full stop depends on the mood
ow
oh
excellent
so how many comments are we going to get
about Frost pots you think
kind of want to go back
it's the one I just got right never mind
we'll we'll try it if we die we die [ __ ]
it
by the way this like area right here is
probably the most beautiful place I've
seen in the game it's one of the most
beautiful places
tri-bleed plot
try frostbot
try pot pie
I'll give you something to try chat
why I Yoda
foreign 's a homie
he's likely Kitty
yeah chat try these nuts
on for size
you like that one that's pretty good
why did you roll through the rot
oh
I mean I don't okay
because I didn't want to walk through it
chat
I know it procs it faster
I don't care if he meant that it procs
faster
that's just a dumbass thing to say and
you all know it
why is chat being so [ __ ] weird the
last two days man it's like I moved and
you guys are just I
okay I gotta calm down I gotta calm down
bro
holy [ __ ] man that's been so weird the
last two days
so weird
I ain't even watching your [ __ ] I'm in
let's go
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
that was trash
that was me by the way
hmm
let's try that again
huh
nice delay
she resistant to Magic
foreign
that I'm so surprised the Arrow does
nothing
absolutely nothing
will the rock sling
I think we just got a slicer
circle around her I swear to [ __ ] God
I I will
I'm saying it now we've done one attempt
one
one so far if anyone in chat says just
circle around her when she does
waterfowl I'm gonna instaban you
it'll be an insta ban just don't say it
okay thank you
holy [ __ ] I hate that comment so much
it's not like it's the easiest thing in
the world to do
if you can good for you but shut up oh
my God it's the most [ __ ] annoying
thing in the world
hmm
besides Frost pots
yeah get Good's fine
of course of course
I kind of I got stuck on her foot
slicer's not very good chat
no you shouldn't have lost any emojis
wow
millennia
blade okay
um
[Music]
um
slow
okay
how many people just got timed out
foreign
decent
I am Millennia blade of Michaela and I
have never known defeat
thank you phosphorus
sure I'm gonna hear that a few more
times
it's not great but it's not bad you know
she's kind of freaking out now though
right this needed to confirm her name
right guys
I always forget her name I I haven't
heard it enough
excellent
I spoke I spoke
what
that's crazy
what
hello
huh
it based on the amount of times you hit
her
we're learning something about waterfowl
right now
is that what triggers her waterfowl is
the amount of times you physically hit
her
so I'm hitting her like a lot more than
usual look
doesn't matter the damage
wow
five was that five
it's it's consecutive hits or something
interesting
I mean it clearly bugs her this this
Starlight thing bugs her her AI
what
I think we're definitely learning
something about her here I've there's no
way anyone's ever seen her do five
waterfowls in a row
that's crazy
or that was just like the buggiest
attempt ever
I gotta keep using it now
so I think you still have to get her to
a certain amount of Health obviously
yeah I'd say at most two's the max I've
seen her do in stage one maybe three if
you take too long
you know
and she gets Health back
you know what I mean
[Applause]
why did I get time now
no no no
I don't even know
never again
you see that [ __ ] delay she does on
that swing sometimes
literally get you killed
okay then why'd you get timed out Geneva
tell me that
that's about where Health would be to
use it right
I think so
I kind of want to bug her out again
yeah yeah
almost perfect
I'm trying to bug her out at this point
okay
not consistent so far
unless she does it right here
um
so hold on
okay it's still happening
it can't be distance because she you can
do it she'll do it when you're right on
top of her
it's not distance
okay this is consistent guys
curious is she reading
each Star as an input is that is that
too crazy to say
just throwing out a potential reason
she's being weird
come on bro she like hit a wall and
that's why she got to hit me
this is really interesting isn't it
foreign
don't know
that was almost dumb
this is so interesting
she only goes to the moon when each star
hits her individually nope that's not
true we're gonna have to throw that
theory out
that disproved that wrong
um
I I don't know what it is
I have no idea
what's causing her to waterfowl over and
over again this is so interesting
I've been trying to figure out why she
does like how she does the waterfowl
for so long
it's just not consistent I mean it it
clearly bugs her waterfowl to do this
attack right
that's clear
but I'm not sure what about it triggers
the waterfowl for her you know
that's what I'm trying to figure out
clear yeah
how many times is that
damn
blade
it's really interesting actually it just
I don't want to use this because it's
just so uh it's so bad
it doesn't do any damage to her
it's like okay
if she reads animations instead of input
maybe it's because the star of runes
animation is a long one
long how though right
long how
she thinks you're the attack
I don't know about that
what I'm thinking is that she thinks of
each
Star as an input
so like every Star that comes at her and
it's quick because they all come at her
really quickly
so I wonder if it's the amount of times
that you actually
at least input and attack it doesn't
have to land but the amount of times you
input because a lot of the waterfowls
there you just throw them all out maybe
one would hit her
and then she would still do the
waterfowl so I'm thinking maybe it's
just inputs
does that make sense
I don't have night comment guys
I don't think do I
okay so I'm gonna put
just go with this I don't think
anything's anything else is really all
that helpful
consecutive hits that trigger damage
no it doesn't have to damage her though
I think it's just consecutive
swings
I think it's just the amount of inputs
you do like me just swinging me using an
attack
that's what it seems like to me
it's based on that
so let's say I was just swinging off in
a random Direction a bunch of times
like this
well let's get her let's get her down to
her health
let's do that first
foreign
sucks unfortunately
it's one of my least favorite attacks in
the entire game
not quite there yet
why is she delaying so much
it are we at
could this technically waterfowl her
that's that's definitely it okay hold on
for science
I think I'm wrong
I think I'm wrong
that's weird
okay maybe I'm not wrong yet
there's the cancel we were talking about
okay science and I'm not I'm gonna lock
onto her this time
it's like she did it
is it ranged attacks
like this
[ __ ]
I think that's it guys
I think that's it
it's ranged attacks
and they don't even have to hit her
hmm
yes
what the [ __ ]
no way
hmm
I am
a blade
that's a note so but why does she
sometimes use waterfowl when you're what
like you could be right on top of her
you can be directly on top of her
and she will
sometimes use it
hmm
oh how we're gonna get their stage two I
think we can [ __ ] kill her if we get
her to stage two with our plan
but I pretty much have to just
annihilator
with the slicer
I didn't realize I
didn't have any stamina
I guess waterfowl is forced when there's
distance
hmm
shorter animation spells I mean wouldn't
a slicer like I was doing be exactly
that and it wasn't triggering her
foreign
thank you
oh yeah everything Melania does looks
amazing
from an artistic standpoint Melania is
amazing
W or L stair
I don't know guys I don't think I'm
doing enough damage with the slicer here
it just takes too many
I should have realized she could
waterfowl there though
I didn't look at her health
foreign
okay
staggered on the first one there but not
the second hit
interesting
I think she can now
yeah
foreign
[Music]
enough damage bro
you know like so you guys notice how I
haven't said anything about Knight Comet
and you guys keep talking about Knight
comet
you would think that me just not saying
anything about Knight comet
would make you think
I don't think he wants to use Knight
comet
so maybe I should stop suggesting night
comment
be wrong
be wrong
but uh
yeah I don't think this damage output is
doable
so I might go get Knight comet
I might go do that
but just a thought it's just a hunch
based on social cues
that uh
you know
you could do that
just a thought
foreign
early
that surprised me her using that there
foreign
she Dodges most long range spells
my character slid blade
we're just not doing enough damage we're
just not
at all
unfortunately
I hate the triple slash
Reaver I'd rather deal with waterfowl
than that [ __ ] triple slash because
sometimes she delays the last slash and
it
makes me mad once when it hits me
sakiro's amazing Henry I hope you you
enjoy the whole game man
um okay
night comment
what's so great about night comment why
are you guys saying night comment
yes KIRO kicks ass
KIRO absolutely kicks ass
she can't dodge it
okay
where where is it I'll just go get it so
everyone shuts up at this point
Brian at this point I just want everyone
to shut up about it
hey just a thought you could tell people
without sounding like a dick just a
thought
are you still [ __ ] mad you got timed
out
apparently
it's like it's my stream or something
and I can talk to you however I want to
and I only have problems with certain
people and I get along with 99 and
because you're one of the one percent
that I called out for being an [ __ ]
in the chat now I'm the [ __ ] that
makes sense
stelia thank you
[ __ ] people dude
just shut up
just shut up
it's not hard
Ian but I'm the [ __ ]
incredible
doesn't make sense to me there's always
one person in the chat like that bro it
just blows my mind that so many people
like that exist you have no social
awareness of how anything works
you think the stream should run around
your suggestions as you keep saying it
over and over again
and you get timed out and then you get
triggered instead of learning from your
mistake and then I'm the [ __ ]
blows my mind every time I hear it
warrant just didn't jump sick
there you go torrent
come on now
give me give me the jumps okay
oh it really is just a [ __ ] my
parents don't pay attention to me so pay
attention to me streamer type situation
oh my God
I should have your parents pay me to
babysit you it's basically what I'm
doing to some of these people I don't
know how to open these I don't remember
I gotta go up there right
I already got that one
that means I have to go actually up top
so hold on
yep yep
over there okay I thought it was closer
than I was
uh mobile memberships are weird Chi
mobile on every live streaming platform
is
broke
it's like sometimes you can and
sometimes you can't
that Tower right there oh that's not one
you can light up
[ __ ]
or is it
oh
whoops
well while I'm here
what is this
I don't remember how to do these at all
other Tower
oh that one thank you
you can see that one
go this way
there
[ __ ]
now
I'm not kidding I'm never I'm never
doing a source rebuild on stream ever
again I'm just not doing it I don't know
what happened to the chat ever since I I
started this build it's it's just been
so [ __ ] annoying I'm sorry I can't
even deal with it man I'd rather
roulette instead of all this [ __ ] where
where's the last Tower
we got this one
is it like in one of those uh things I
gotta break down there type of thing
it's not it's literally just some people
it's it's not all of chat
roulette run again it's funny how if we
did it again
it would probably be completely
different
so that's enticing
sir
all small doors open now thank you
eldrake is that good
is there another door open over here
here
okay that's something
only good against Ronaldo that's what I
thought
other tower that you skipped I don't
know what tower you're talking about
that one doesn't light up
bum
one more chest in the middle right here
damn
hey
are you all happy now [ __ ] dude
holy all right that's all we wanted
I am Melania
twisted
thank you man
thank you for another five gifted from
Mr twisties
I appreciate that a lot thank you thank
you
if you get a gifted from Twisted make
sure to say thank you as always
Twisted going crazy yet again yet again
uh here
www
.twistedispoggers.com
hello
all right
let's see how good night comb it is
check it out
it'll make a difference trust okay
here we go
she can't see it
it's making a difference
so is it just her that can't see it
or do all NPCs not see it
definitely made a difference it's
most okay
you can't see it in PvP either
whoa
yes you can
a little unlucky with the wall there
I ditched my nose for at least 25
seconds there
yep it's triggering her waterfowls
though which is okay
it's okay with me man
[Music]
a lot of waterfowls
did they just add in for her to spam
waterfowl for arranged attacks
just so she couldn't be cheese that way
I mean look at this that's how many now
my character won't run I dodged it holy
[ __ ]
I'm the guy at salmon or something
because this is a lot
there you go
night comet is pretty good
foreign
bye bye
uh oh
is that just unlucky I guess I don't
know
that just straight up
unlucky
I don't know
look at her spaz out
yep it's because I said bye bye that's
why
for sure
[Music]
hi sweet girl
not the best time for pets
oh
Joy's here
hi baby
what are you doing
you take a nap
no it's not time to eat yet
you got another 50 minutes till you need
to eat Jojo
she tries to beg to eat early
not time
oh
[Music]
man I don't know why sometimes my
characters won't run
Harry hotter just doesn't want to go
I should have shot her again
we better cancel that animation
okay
thank you
I got stuck
uh
[ __ ]
run man
she just canceled an animation into the
same animation
oh dude this sucks
[Music]
no [ __ ] way that hit me
you're high
foreign
[Music]
I I didn't have stamina I guess I know I
hit the Dodge
I know I hit the Dodge
[ __ ]
I don't think I had stamina man that
sucks
that one hurt
Man without the FP bar common Azure is
not the best
yeah I needed to make sure my FP bar was
full there too I just wanted to get the
hits off you know
no I don't think I have the Aero
Talisman on
foreign
she's barking at something
hey Joy
no we don't do that hey
no
no okay she can growl
you guys see her
honey
she's just hungry and wants to eat so
she's like being annoying till I feed
her
oh those aren't reaching I'm sad
as long as she's not loud barking I
don't mind the growls
I don't want loud barks
it's probably some dog out there
there's a lot of dogs here
calm down
what the [ __ ]
what was that movement from her
I do the same thing against your
waterfowl every time and sometimes
she'll just like move weird
for some reason my stamina is acting
weird as well
yes I have radicon's icon
oh my God
what the [ __ ]
I don't get it
not as many frost pots
suggestions as usual
but I'm I'm literally getting a point
where every time I look at Chad I just
want to turn off the stream bro I'm so
annoyed at this point
I'm just annoyed I I don't want to play
this character on stream anymore it's
it's not fun at all
to have people just want to change my
build constantly
to be the most perfectly balanced
whatever the [ __ ] it's called
uh
when you try to make your character the
most efficient I don't know what is that
called again I'm drawing a blank
my God I'm not talking whatever
optimize mid-maxing that
well I didn't even get to do my thing
you don't have to do what we say
I know
I'm actively not doing what you say for
the most part
it's just the fact people don't stop
and then when I don't they get butt hurt
and act like literal [ __ ] in the chat
to be honest
foreign
and then you yelled at me for not doing
it
it's just weird I've noticed the DraStic
difference in the way the chat acts
since I started doing this build
it's so apparent
by the Scarlet rocked
well he spells this take forever
I also just don't like fighting her
either
I don't enjoy Millennia at all we all we
all know this though
foreign
I'm mainly just over it at this point I
don't know I don't know what it is
I'm just not having fun streaming this
build today or yesterday to be honest
come on run
why he doesn't run sometimes
[Music]
run man what the [ __ ] is up with this
guy
all right guys I'm done I'm sorry I'm
just gonna walk joy and and be done I'm
I'm not gonna stream this character
anymore I'm over it it it's led to like
the worst chat experience I've had
streaming
and I'm I'm over it I'm just not having
fun
I stream to have fun and this just isn't
fun so we'll do something else tomorrow
but I'm not I'm not doing this
I I'm so tired of it bro it's literally
just put me in a state of just like I'm
[ __ ]
I don't want to be here
so
I don't know what to do I'm literally
just people it's just it's not it's
literally two percent of chat and I
shouldn't let two percent affect me but
it's it's been a bit more than than
usual today and yesterday I was over it
yesterday and I like let's go again
today
and I'm just realizing that I don't know
what it is
I don't know what it is about this
character
and it being an intelligence wizard
build or whatever that makes people come
out of the woodwork to mid-max my
character
I guess people do that on my Bonk builds
as well like the strength builds they'll
do the exact same thing but
whatever reason it's come out of [ __ ]
nowhere I'm just so tired of hearing it
and then when I call them out to stop
doing it they call me the [ __ ] which
makes me feel like [ __ ]
so I don't I don't know what it is about
people in this build but I'm over it
dude sorry so I'm sorry that's it that's
all I can say about it it just has not
been fun at all
so I'm gonna walk her
are you hungry
yeah
can you wait a minute
you get up here
okay
no I'll be fine once I turn the stream
off bro it's just I don't know what it
is it's was pissing me off today dude
so many people in the chat like that bro
so many
um
sorry
um yeah I don't know how to avoid it
either like I guess I could just do
everything that they're saying so that
they stop saying it
I I so I don't know what to do I really
don't uh
come into my stream reject my build and
call me an [ __ ]
yeah
that's kind of how the last two days
have been
their suggestions were [ __ ]
then I don't know why they're suggesting
it
I don't know
so I want to finish this but
I mean we we definitely could have went
and just beat radagon and uh eldenbees
but obviously one Millennia pisses me
off but it's like a requirement to fight
her at this point
bye
Joy's a good girl though members only
stream nah it's not it's not worth it
I don't know dude I don't like being
called an [ __ ] I don't like that
either
not a fan of that
uh when I know I'm not
heading to Grammy's
sorry I have not looked at my phone all
day today
okay
yeah I'm sure some of the suggestions
are good I just don't get why it's such
a big deal for me to do something
different
than what they did
you know
that I don't understand
like there's there's so many different
build varieties
and it's like if I'm not doing what they
did
try ignoring it's [ __ ] impossible
Julian I've I've done that and it leads
to me not even being able to read the
chat like I just can't
it's it'll it didn't
impresses me how how far how many times
people will suggest something
over and over and over again bro so
that's all that's all like you know we
we do we we try speed running
probably won't have these suggestions
from people you know what I mean
because that's a very like finite route
finite build we do that we do it as fast
as we can
that sounds fun to me
we're at challenge without it this time
nah
I definitely want to do the Vigor run
the only Vigor run that could be very
interesting
now and again it's only just some people
but it's it was enough people the last
two days for me just to be like wow
this is so annoying
uh and I don't like feeling that way man
I I stream to have fun and talk to my
community so
um
yeah
I didn't do a very good job of that the
last two days so we'll we'll come back
tomorrow and try to do uh
try to have fun
but the this wizard build on stream like
I'll probably finish it off stream just
playing on my own but dude on stream has
been just the most uh
just not fun
that's always it
you could always turn off chat
I then why am I live streaming
you know what I mean
that's just silly I just shouldn't be
live if I'm gonna be streaming without
chat on
that'd be silly
um
the people here regularly know that when
you're stressed
it's not fun to stream anymore
dude it's not that I'm stressed it's
just like
I don't know I don't know man it doesn't
matter
it doesn't matter
but I want to try the speed run that's
that's my next stream thing until we hit
another milestone
so
we'll try that tomorrow I'll get it all
set up and everything but I'm gonna feed
Joy are you hungry yes
you see your head probably not are you
hungry
you are
where are you
you want to eat and then we go for a big
walk
[Music]
yeah I'll be a glitchless speedrun I
don't I don't want to do any of the
major glitches but I want to do it as
fast as I can just being good at the
bosses and getting a cool weapon and
whatever
hi
okay well we'll be back tomorrow
hope you all have a great rest of your
day I'm sorry these streams kind of
sucked
uh but now we know
if I had to say it's kind of like the
the type of build brings out different
personalities right so like when
somebody who is like a wizard all the
time sees somebody playing as a wizard
they come in and try to min max
hard
and it's just like oh
and then you know four and a half hours
plus five hours yesterday that's a lot
to where I'm just gonna get annoyed so
again I'm sorry guys uh we'll be back
tomorrow
and I'll see you then boys and girls
have a great rest of your day great rest
of your night
and uh
we'll try and get get good at the speed
run so
bye guys have a great time